in this lesson we're going to talk about
the quadratic formula and the
discriminant two concepts that are very
important on that SI t so first of all
what you want to know is this equation
right here ax squared plus bx plus c
equals 0 it's a quadratic because it's
to the second degree right but if you
want to solve this equation when it's
equal to 0 like this you would take the
coefficients in front of the variables a
B and C and you would put them into the
quadratic formula right here and this
will give you the answer for the x
values now you can see the plus or minus
so there's a potential for two solutions
now the discriminant is just this part
here that's underneath the square root
it's the b squared minus 4ac and if this
is greater than zero meaning positive it
means we get two real solutions meaning
the parabola if you were to graph it
would cross the x-axis at two points if
it's equal to zero to discriminate then
that means you have one real solution
and it's going to just be crossing the
excess set x axis at one point right at
the vertex and then if it's less than
zero meaning that the discriminant is
negative then it means you have zero
real solutions but two imaginary or two
complex solutions what that means is if
you graph the parabola it's not going to
cross the x-axis these are going to look
like those where it's opening up or
opening down but it's not going to
intersect that x axis so let's get into
some examples so you can get some
experience example one says what is the
sum of all the solutions to the equation
x squared minus 4x minus 10 equals 0 so
what is the sum okay of all the
solutions well you could try to factor
this and set the fashions is 0 and solve
but this was not factorable so that's
where the quadratic formula comes in so
go ahead and see if you can solve this
one on your own pause the video and
we'll go through it together so in this
example you can see that j equals 1 b
equals negative 4 and c equals negative
10 so i'm going to put that into the
quadratic formula right here so the
opposite of view of the opposite of
negative 4 which is positive 4 plus or
minus the square root of a negative 4
squared notice I put that in parentheses
so that's going to be minus 4 times a
which is 1 times c which is negative 10
it's all in e cos square root / 2 times
a which is 2 times 1 so all we have to
do now is simplify this
and so we get four plus or minus the
square root of negative 4 squared is 16
a negative 4 times 1 times negative 10
is actually like a positive 40 right all
/ to notice a negative times a negative
deposit okay so we get 4 plus or minus
the square root of 56 all over 2 square
root of 56 is really like four times 14
which really gives you two square root
of 14 so this is actually four plus or
minus two square root of 14 all over two
and we can divide both these terms by
two so that would be 2 plus or minus 1
square root of 14 so our two answers are
two plus square root of 14 and two minus
square root of 14 but it's asking us for
the sum of the solution so if we add
these together two plus two is four
square root of 14 plus negative squared
of fortune that 0 so some is just going
to be 4 so letter B is going to be the
best answer so they added out a couple
little you know twists where they had
that you had to add the solutions
together that was a little bit an extra
step and then the head you do the
quadratic formula because it wasn't
factorable okay let's go to example
number two so this one says 3x squared
minus 6x plus C equals zero now the six
looks a little bit like a bee but this
is a six year so it says in the equation
above he is a constant meaning just like
a number if the equation has exactly one
real solution which of the following can
be the value of C is it a B C or D okay
so pause the video see if you can do
this problem and we'll go through it
together so in order for to have exactly
one real solution that means that the
discriminant here has to equal zero so
what we're looking at here is b squared
minus 4ac has to be equal to zero well B
squared is negative 6 squared minus 4
times a which is three times C we don't
know let's just call it Z equals zero so
this is negative 6 squared which is 36
minus 12 c equals 0 we subtract 36 from
both sides we get negative 12 C equals
negative 36 and if we divide everything
by negative 12 we get see you
those three so it looks like the best
answer here is letter B and you've got
it so again you want to memorize these
formulas the quadratic formula and also
the discriminant and be able to remember
how many solutions they have so
definitely something important
understand for the s80 go ahead and
review this less than a few you too and
i'll see you in the next lesson